[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: So last time,
we discussed glycolysis
as a pathway.
And I just want to
remind everybody
that, like all pathways,
glycolysis has to be favorable.
That is, delta G across
the entire pathway
has to be less than 0.
We spent a lot of
time discussing
the regulation of glycolysis.
And I just want to
revisit this quickly.
And remember, we discussed that
the steps that are regulated
are those with the
biggest, quote, unquote,
bio-energetic cost.
That is, the biggest
drop in delta G
is as molecules would
proceed across the pathway.
And those are shown here--
the hexokinase step,
the phosphofructokinase
step, and the pyruvate kinase
step of the pathway.
Now this is largely true of most
pathways that we will consider,
in that these regulated
steps are often
those with the biggest
bio-energetic cost.
And the reason for that is
that it makes a lot of sense.
Once you go through those steps,
it's very difficult to go back.
Also, you'll note that
these are the steps that
regulate entrance and
exit from the pathway.
And this also is something we'll
commonly see and other pathways
and also makes some sense.
Just to remind
everybody, I drew up
here a skeletonized
version of glycolysis
and the most important
regulatory features of it.
Just to remind people
that initially,
hexokinase is regulated
by glucose-6 phosphate.
Glucose-6 phosphate negatively
regulates hexokinase.
And that's because if the
glucose-6 phosphate levels
in the cell go up such that it
can't be shunted to glycogen--
something we'll
talk about today--
or be sent through
glycolysis, it
makes sense not to
trap more glucose.
Once glucose-6 phosphate
enters the rest
of the glycolytic pathway,
the key step of regulation
is phosphofructokinase.
It, of course, will have
positive feedback, saying,
let's put carbon
into the pathway.
If energy charge low, AMP
is high, activates it.
This molecule fructose
2,6-bisphosphate that we talked
about earlier today--
we'll mention again today--
can be involved in some
other signaling inputs
to allosterically
regulate the enzyme.
FBP can feed forward to
activate pyruvate kinase.
You want to match
input with output.
And, of course, if PEP builds
up, you want to slow it down.
If a downstream product--
citrate-- builds up, you
want to slow it down.
And of course, a major
output of glycolysis is ATP.
And if ATP is high, no reason
to continue oxidizing glucose
carbons.
Now this regulation
we discussed is often
done at the allosteric level
by controlling enzyme rates.
That can be via a small molecule
binding, as I've shown up here.
And it could also
be via signaling.
And that's really a place
where fructose 2,6-bisphosphate
as a combination of signaling,
and allosteric small molecules
comes into play.
That is, you can have signaling
that controls the enzymes that
generate fructose
2,6-bisphosphate,
thereby creating an additional
molecule that can act
as allosteric regulator of
the enzyme PFK to generate FBP
and commit carbon to glycolysis.
Now we closed the
discussion last time
beginning to discuss
how it is that organisms
can make glucose.
Obviously, this
glucose carbon that
is being oxidized to get ATP
has to come from somewhere.
We mentioned that plants
make glucose during the day
when they have plenty of excess
energy from light from the sun
but then use that glucose to do
constant metabolism to maintain
their ATP levels at night.
And we as animals obviously
take advantage of this
by eating the glucose
that ultimately
was created by plants using
the energy of the sun.
We began to discuss an example
of where us, as organisms, also
make glucose.
Of course, this is not
net production of glucose.
But for instance, if our
muscle cells are working hard,
lactate can build up.
That lactate is
excreted into the blood.
That lactate can then
be used by the liver
to regenerate glucose.
And one of the major
jobs of the liver
is to maintain a constant
level of blood glucose
to continue to supply
fuel for various organs,
including the muscle to be
able to carry out the work
that it needs to do.
And so this whole process
is called the Cori cycle.
And a major job of
the liver is thus
generating glucose to
maintain blood glucose levels.
And the pathways
used to do this is
a pathway that we began
to talk about last time
called gluconeogenesis.
And it's really a discussion
of gluconeogenesis.
That is, how can one
build a pathway in plants,
in the liver, wherever, as
a way to generate glucose
from something like lactate?
Now, of course, we
know from last time,
lactate dehydrogenase
can, obviously, it's
a redox reaction to
interconvert with pyruvate.
And what gluconeogenesis
really is
it's a pathway that
cells use to convert
pyruvate or really anything else
that can come into glycolysis--
and example being lactate.
This, of course, can happen
by the lactate dehydrogenase
reaction.
And then once it
has that pyruvate,
turn that pyruvate into glucose.
That's really what we're
talking about when we're
discussing gluconeogenesis.
Now how can we turn
pyruvate into glucose?
Well, we just discussed
the whole pathway
where we could turn glucose
into pyruvate-- glycolysis.
And so this is really the
reverse of glycolysis.
I said many times that all
enzymes are reversible.
So why can't we
just run the pathway
in the opposite direction?
Well, hopefully, if you've
been paying attention
for the last several
lectures, you
realize there's two
problems with doing that.
The first is that, remember,
why we're doing metabolism
in the first place is to
maintain a high ATP:ADP ratio
under conditions so that the
cell can use that ATP:ADP ratio
to carry out otherwise
unfavorable processes.
And so thus, at a
very high level,
cells can't stop catabolism.
Glycolysis or whatever has
to continue to maintain
ATP in the right range.
And so now, if we're going to
do something anabolic-- that is,
build something,
turn it into glucose,
this has to happen
in the background
where catabolism
has still happened.
And so at least you
need some kind of way
to control both and
prevent this from being
some kind of futile cycle.
Second, even if that ATP level
is super high in the cell,
it has extra energy, there is
still a thermodynamic problem
with just reversing glycolysis.
And that is, remember, delta
G has to be less than 0
for any pathway to work.
And so it then stands to reason
that if glucose oxidation
to pyruvate, if this
reaction is favored,
as it is in glycolysis,
that delta G is less than 0.
Well, under the conditions
where that's occurring,
if we want to then say,
well, what about the reverse?
Let's switch the signs--
pyruvate to glucose.
We know that delta
G is the same as it
was in the opposite
direction but,
now, changing the signs
from positive to negative
or negative positive.
And so, thus, delta G,
for the reverse reaction,
must be greater than
0 and, therefore, must
be spontaneous--
is not spontaneous.
And therefore says that we need
to have a different pathway
simply for energetic
reasons if we're
going to go in the
opposite direction.
Now oxidizing glucose
releases energy.
That's how we keep the
ATP:ADP ratio high.
It stands to reason
then that we are
going to have to put energy
in if we're going to run
in the opposite direction.
And so if we're going to
build a pathway from pyruvate
to glucose, you can guess, we're
going to have to add couple
that pathway to
ATP-ADP hydrolysis--
that is, couple it to something
favorable to now allow
this otherwise unfavorable
reaction to happen.
Now this energy, of course, in
plants can come from the sun.
We'll discuss that
in great detail
when we get to photosynthesis.
However, for the sake
of you and I, I guess,
what it says is, if
you think about this,
if you release energy from
glycolysis, it makes sense
then you have to
add energy if you're
going to do gluconeogenesis.
But remember, to satisfy all
the laws of thermodynamics,
the net energy loss to the
universe is going to be--
must exist, which
means that it is
going to cost more
energy to make glucose
than you're going to get
back from breaking it down.
That just, hopefully,
fits with your intuition.
And it actually, I
guess, is good news,
because when are we
going to do anabolism?
When are we going to store
all these excess calories
as glucose?
Well, we're going to
do it if we overeat.
And if we overeat,
and it costs us
energy in the form of
calories to actually store
that energy for later, I guess,
it means that when we overeat,
we don't have things quite
as bad as it could have been.
All right.
Now let's get back to the
how one can actually do this.
So if we want to think,
what is a pathway
that we can build to get from
pyruvate back to glucose?
Well, we know we're going to
have to burn some ATP to do it.
But what are the issues with
simply reversing glycolysis?
Well, we can come back
here and say, well,
what was driving glycolysis
in the first place?
And it was these big steps
of free energy change
acts of hexokinase,
phosphofructokinase,
and pyruvate kinase.
Where as many of
these other reactions,
at least under these
standard conditions that
are estimated to exist
in cells, are relatively
close to equilibrium.
So there's really no problem
with reversing glycolysis
across here or across there.
The real issue comes from
getting around the hexokinase
to phosphofructokinase and
the pyruvate kinase step.
These are the places
where the most energy
is released, if you
will, when you're
going through glycolysis.
So those are the
steps we're going
to have to add energy in order
to reverse build a pathway that
goes in the opposite
direction and allows
you to start with pyruvate
and end up with glucose.
And so what we will find is that
gluconeogenesis and glycolysis
use many of the same enzymes.
However, not all of the
enzymes are the same
because we need
different enzymes
if we're going to get
around this hexokinase,
phosphofructokinase, and
pyruvate kinase steps
of the pathway.
And so for gluconeogenesis,
we essentially
need four new enzymes in order
to get past those places.
So we're going to need
a new enzyme called
glucose 6-phosphatase.
And glucose
6-phosphatase is going
to allow us to get from
glucose 6-phosphate
and turn it back into glucose.
All right.
We're going to need an enzyme
fructose 1,6-bisphosphatase,
which is going to allow us
to take FBP and turn it back
into fructose 6-phosphate.
And then we're going to need
two enzymes to get around
the pyruvate kinase step.
These are two enzymes
called PEPCK and PC.
That stands for
phosphoenolpyruvate
carboxykinase and
pyruvate carboxylase.
I'll discuss these in
great detail in a minute.
And these are going to allow
us to get from pyruvate back
to PEP.
Also, essentially, I'll add
them up here to this diagram.
So to get back from pyruvate
to PEP, two enzymes--
pyruvate carboxylase
and phosphoenolpyruvate
carboxykinase to get from
fructose 1,6-bisphosphate,
fructose 6-phosphate,
an enzyme called FBPase.
And to get from glucose
6-phosphate back to glucose,
an enzyme called
glucose 6-phosphatase.
OK.
Now, of course,
if you think back,
we're also going to need
to balance electrons
in the pathway.
Remember, glucose to pyruvate
is an oxidation reaction.
That is, we're generating NADH.
That means to go in
the reverse direction,
we need a source of NADH to
reverse that GAPDH reaction.
I just want to point
out that you're only
doing gluconeogenesis if
cells have plenty of energy.
What does plenty of energy mean?
Well, that means the
ATP:ADP ratio is high
because you're doing
lots of metabolism.
But if you're doing
lots of metabolism,
and the ATP:ADP ratio's high,
that also means the NADH/NAD+
ratio is high.
And so you can think
of the NAD regeneration
by gluconeogenesis as being,
for all intents and purposes,
an alternative to
fermentation, if you will,
as a way to keep
catabolism going.
That is, you're only
doing this if you
have plenty of NADH around.
And so dealing with
that electron balance
is less of an issue.
OK.
Now let's discuss briefly how
some of these enzymes work.
So glucose 6-phosphate and
fructose 1,6-bisphosphatase are
very straightforward.
Effectively, all they are is
simply removing a phosphate.
That's very favorable.
Remember, when we
did those reactions
of hexokinase
phosphofructokinase reactions
and glycolysis, that, we
had to couple otherwise
unfavorable things--
adding a phosphate
group to ATP hydrolysis.
This is the reverse of that.
And so the reverse
of that, delta G
is going to be less than 0.
Delta G less than 0 means we
just have a phosphatase there,
just like you might
have on a kinase enzyme.
That's very straightforward.
But there's a much bigger issue
to get around this other step,
this pyruvate kinase step.
Remember, equilibrium
strongly favored
PEP to pyruvate conversion.
That was one of the reasons
why we could use that step
to maintain a high
ATP:ADP ratio in cells.
Well, now, the issue
becomes, how can we
trap that phosphate
back onto pyruvate
while generating
phosphoenolpyruvate?
How one does that is an issue.
Even if the ATP:ADP
ratio is high,
it's never high enough to
reverse pyruvate kinase on its
own.
And so we need a new pathway
with two steps in it.
That's why there's two enzymes--
PC and PEPCK-- that are there
to create a pathway where
pyruvate to PEP now
becomes favorable.
That is, where delta G
0 prime is less than 0.
That is, the equilibrium
favors to the right.
And under cellular
conditions, this pathway
can actually happen such that
cells can net make glucose.
Now these are two steps,
both of which require ATP.
And so you effectively
get one ATP from PEP
to pyruvate conversion.
It costs you to ADPs
or two ADP equivalents
to go back from pyruvate
to PEP, which makes sense.
You should have to
spend more energy
to go upstream than you
get back coming downstream.
All right.
Here's how this pathway works.
So this is pyruvate,
the first reaction
catalyzed by PC, which stands
for pyruvate carboxylase.
Couples ATP
hydrolysis to addition
of a CO2 that generates
this intermediate, which
is called oxaloacetate,
often abbreviated
OAA for Oxaloacetic Acid.
That oxaloacetate is
then decarboxylated.
That is, the CO2 that
is lost is removed--
that was added is removed.
This reaction is coupled
to GTP and is catalyzed
by this enzyme, PEPCK
PEP carboxykinase
and uses that phosphate
from GTP to trap pyruvate in
the enol form as PEP
or phosphoenolpyruvate.
great.
So once you've
regenerated PEP, now
that PEP gets to this flat
part, if we go over here
to our delta G place.
So now it can easily run
back across this flat part
of the curve.
That is, go through enolase
phosphoglycerate mutase,
phosphoglycerate kinase, GAPDH,
taking advantage of the high
NADH/NAD+ ratio that would
exist when you're doing
gluconeogenesis--
triosephosphate isomerase,
aldolase.
This generates a DHAP and a
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate that
you can then combine to give
a fructose 1,6-bisphosphate.
Now we get back here to now
we have this steep part there.
But rather than
going through FBP,
we can just have a phosphatase,
fructose 1,6-bisphosphatase
that releases the phosphate.
Now, we have
fructose 6-phosphate.
That fructose
6-phosphate can then
go through glucose
6-phosphate isomerase
and generate
glucose 6-phosphate.
That now gets back to
this other steep hill.
So this is relatively flat.
Now, you have this steep
hill around hexokinase.
But rather than coupling it to
adding to ATP-ADP hydrolysis,
you just remove the phosphate
with glucose 6-phosphatase.
And in the end, now
we have a pathway
using these four extra
enzymes that give us
a way to start at pyruvate
and run the opposite direction
and generate glucose.
And you can do so in a way that
is thermodynamically favorable.
In other words, we can start
with 2 pyruvate and use 4 ATP--
so and ATP to turn pyruvate
twice into oxaloacetate.
So that's two.
And then another ATP at
phosphoglycerate kinase
to go backwards
there to go from--
to run that reaction
backwards, plus 2 GTP.
Those 2 GTP are effectively
the equivalent of an ATP.
So this would be
6 ATP equivalents.
Why are the GTPs
equivalent of ATP?
I just want to point out
that cells have enzymes
that basically can interconvert
ATP and GDP or, really,
any nucleoside triphosphate and
diphosphate to GTP plus ADP.
This has a delta G 0 prime
that is effectively 0.
And so cells basically
match their ATP
to ADP ratios with
any other ratios
of nucleoside triphosphates
and diphosphates because
of this reaction.
And so that's why the two GTP
are roughly an ATP equivalent.
So we'll just call
it 6 ATP plus 2 NADH
to reverse the GAPDH step.
That gives us 6 ADP plus 2 NAD+
plus 6 inorganic phosphate plus
a glucose.
The delta G 0 prime for
this entire coupled pathway
is on the order of
negative 9 kcals per mol,
with the delta G less than 0,
equilibrium lies to the right.
Net synthesis of
glucose is favorable.
And so if we just think
about this in ATP terms,
remember, when we
discussed glycolysis,
you harvest net two ATP
from conversion of glucose
into two pyruvate.
If we reverse the reaction doing
gluconeogenesis, in ATP terms,
we have to invest six ATP
to turn that pyruvate back
into glucose.
Makes sense.
We didn't make a
perpetual motion machine.
Both pathways are favorable.
But it costs more energy to make
a glucose than we can get out
by burning the glucose.
I should say, the energy
isn't just the ATP.
There's also this NADH.
That NADH that's produced from
glycolysis also is storing
energy, if you will, from
oxidation and an NADH/NAD+
ratio, and you're consuming
that going in the opposite
direction.
You only do gluconeogenesis if
you have a high ATP:ADP ratio,
of course, and a
NADH/NAH+ plus ratio--
that is, if you have it
under the right conditions
to actually run this
pathway and have
it make sense for the cell.
All right.
Now I want to
discuss, briefly, how
these enzymes in
gluconeogenesis work.
I'm not going to spend time
on fructose 1,6-bisphosphatase
or glucose 6-phosphatase.
As I said before, this
is just hydrolysis
of that phosphate-alcohol bond.
That's relatively
straightforward.
But I do want to spend time
on pyruvate carboxylase
and PEP carboxykinase
because this introduces
a new reaction, carboxylation.
But it also introduces a
new concept in metabolism
that is actually quite
important in eukaryotic cells.
And that is this issue of
so-called compartmentalized
metabolism.
And, of course, you've learned
in introductory biology
that a big difference between
eukaryotes and prokaryotes
is eukaryotes have all of
these organelles-- that
is, these membrane-bound
structures within cells that
carry out various functions.
So one reason that
it's useful to have
these different
membrane-bound organelles
is it creates different
compartments within the cell.
What does that mean?
Well, if you have
different compartments,
that means you can create
different conditions
within each compartment.
And that's very
important for metabolism.
Well, why is that
important for metabolism?
Well, because, remember, whether
or not reactions are favorable
depend on delta G,
which, of course, is
dependent on the
equilibrium constant, which
is related to delta
G 0 prime but also
to the ratio of the
products and reactants
within that compartment.
And so by having
different compartments,
you can have different
ratios of metabolites-- say,
a different ratio of ATP to ATP
or a different ratio of NADH
to NAD+.
Having those different ratios
means that because delta G is
proportional to the ratio of the
reactants over the products--
I'm sorry-- products
over reactants,
by having different
ratios of things
like ATP and ADP, NAD, NADH,
you can make different reactions
more or less favorable
depending on which
compartment in the cell
that they're located.
Now it turns out that glycolysis
and most of gluconeogenesis
takes place in the cytosol
of eukaryotic cells.
The cytosol is
basically the space
inside the cell that's not
inside another organelle.
However, pyruvate carboxylase
is a reaction that takes place
in mitochondria because
mitochondria have
a particularly
high ATP:ADP ratio.
And it turns out, this helps
favor the pyruvate carboxylase
reaction.
And so we'll talk a lot about
reactions in the site cytosol
versus the mitochondria.
But basically, here's
glucose to PEP.
Whether you do that in one
direction by glycolysis
or the other direction
by gluconeogenesis,
that happens in
the cytosol as does
turning that PEP into pyruvate.
But if you're going to
reverse the reaction,
eukaryotes take advantage
of a different compartment,
the mitochondria, with
a high ATP to ADP ratio.
And basically, in
the mitochondria,
turn that pyruvate
into oxaloacetic acid--
that is, carry out the
pyruvate carboxylase reaction.
And then that pyruvate
carboxylase reaction
generates oxaloacetic
acid, and then PEPCK
can, either in the
mitochondria or in the cytosol,
generate PEP.
And so here's a place where
one can run one reaction--
PEP to pyruvate of t
make ATP in the cytosol--
but a different reaction--
pyruvate carboxylase
to turn pyruvate
into oxaloacetic
acid that would then
be used for PEPCK to
turn that back into PEP
and have that take place
in the mitochondria.
I want to point out, just so
for MCAT exams and things like
that, PEPCK is
classically defined
as a cytosolic
activity, at least
in terms of gluconeogenesis.
Although, there is a
mitochondrial isoform of PEPCK.
And it's at least
somewhat debated.
There's some evidence
that, at least,
in some tissues, that might be
important for gluconeogenesis
as well.
And so that's why I draw it
as PEPCK using oxaloacetate
to PEP either in the
mitochondria or in the cytosol
because that's an area of
active investigation right now.
All right.
Let's start by talking about how
does pyruvate carboxylase work?
This is an example of a
carboxylase reaction, that is,
adding a CO2 group to a molecule
to make a carbon-carbon bond.
That purple CO2 is added
to the CH3 of pyruvate of
to make oxaloacetate.
And how this happens, in
many cases, uses a cofactor.
And that cofactor
is called biotin.
Biotin, like many
cofactors, is a vitamin.
And this provides a
useful functional group.
In this case, enzymes
that use biotin
use ATP to basically drive
CO2 addition to biotin.
And then that CO2 on
the biotin is then
activated to be transferred
to another molecule
in a carboxylation reaction.
All right.
So what does biotin look like?
I will draw it for you.
So this, here, would be biotin.
I've drawn it in the
enolate form of biotin.
I'll draw it in a
different way in a second.
Biotin is typically bound
to a lysine molecule
in the active site of an
enzyme that uses this.
And so this, here, is
basically a peptide bond
between the terminal amino
group, the epsilon amino group
of the side chain of
a lysine in a residue
that basically
makes a peptide bond
to link biotin into the active
site of the enzyme that's
using it.
Biotin is often drawn
in the keto form.
And the active part
of biotin is basically
this top part of the molecule.
And so to draw it to see
differences between the enolate
and keto form, I just
want to show that quickly.
I drew it in the enolate
form because it's easier
to see, I think, how it--
so this, here, would
be the keto form where
biotin is drawn most commonly.
And basically, the
reaction, the way biotin
picks up a CO2 is as follows.
And that is CO2 can
exist particularly
under basic conditions
as CO2 or as--
this is bicarbonate.
OK.
So bicarbonate-- turns out,
some enzymes use CO2 directly.
Some enzymes use bicarbonate.
It turns out that pyruvate
carboxylase uses bicarbonate.
So biotin bound in the active
site of pyruvate carboxylase
will utilize bicarbonate
in the following way.
And I'll just point out that
the pH of the mitochondria
is also more basic,
which also helps
this pyruvate
carboxylation reaction.
All right.
So what happens is
this bicarbonate
is phosphorylated by ATP.
This phospho
intermediate can then
react with this active
site here of biotin
to release the phosphate.
And now, you now have
this activated CO2 group
that's attached to the biotin.
Here's pyruvate drawn
in the enol form.
You can look back in your notes
about how to interconvert it
between keto and the enol form.
I've shown that several times.
And then this, then, can
end up adding this CO2
to the end of
pyruvate to generate
oxaloacetic acid plus
regenerate the biotin
cofactor in the right form.
It'll be the keto
form, which can then
get back to the enol form.
And it's ready to do
another catalytic cycle.
And so, basically,
pyruvate carboxylase
uses ATP to produce this
carboxylate of biotin.
And then uses that
to add the CO2
to pyruvate to generate
oxaloacetic acid.
Now I want to point out
that oxaloacetic acid is
both an alpha keto
acid like pyruvate was.
And it's a beta keto acid.
And so this ketone is alpha
to that carboxylic acid.
And it's beta to
that carboxylic acid.
So it's both an alpha
and a beta keto acid.
And it turns out
that the way PEPCK
works is it takes advantage of
the favorable decarbonization
of a beta keto acid,
which we talked about
last time, along with GTP to
phosphorylate pyruvate and trap
it in the enol form.
And so this is how PEPCK works.
So I'm going to draw GTP
in this very stylized way--
so guanine with three
phosphate groups.
There's oxaloacetate.
That decarboxylates--
takes advantage
of this being a beta keto
acid to decarboxylate and add
the phosphate.
And that's how we
can generate PEP.
OK.
Great.
And so that's how you can
build a different pathway that
uses ATP and GTP
for energy input
in order to run glycolysis
in the opposite direction--
gluconeogenesis.
All right.
So how is gluconeogenesis
regulated?
Well, just like the principles
we talked about in glycolysis,
it works in a way
that makes sense.
And so you can guess
that the steps that
are going to be
regulated are exactly
the ones that you might guess.
They were the same
steps that were
regulated running glycolysis.
It's going to be these
big changes where
energy changes occur across
the pathway, which are also
the entrance and
exit of the pathway.
And basically, regulation
has to be reciprocal.
So in glycolysis, you want
to increase glycolysis
under conditions where
you need to produce ATP.
And you want to
decrease glycolysis
if you have enough ATP or enough
of another downstream product,
such as citrate.
All right.
Well, gluconeogenesis is going
to be exactly the opposite.
You certainly don't want
to do gluconeogenesis
if you need energy release.
If you need ATP, you don't
want to run gluconeogenesis.
However, you want to
increase gluconeogenesis,
if the cell has ATP
excess, you also
want to do it if you have
excess of other products
like citrate because why go
through the trouble of sending
things down glycolysis if
you have nowhere to put it.
You might as well, instead, make
glucose or shunt that glucose
off to produce glycogen.
And so let me just add
that regulation here.
And so major regulators of
gluconeogenesis are as follows.
And so high levels of citrate
is going to stimulate fructose
1,6-bisphosphatase.
So high levels of citrate will
inhibit things coming through
glycolysis and activate
gluconeogenesis by acting
at fructose 1,6-bisphosphatase
to match the energy
considerations.
If you have high levels of
AMP, energy charge is low.
You want to stimulate glycolysis
at phosphofructokinase.
Similarly, that's going
to inhibit gluconeogenesis
at FBPase.
And it turns out,
high levels of ADP--
I'm sorry-- yeah, high levels
of ADP, low energy charge,
also inhibits PEPCK
because you also
don't want to try to generate
PEP under those conditions.
Great.
All right.
Now in animals, we also want
to regulate glucose catabolism
and production under
signaling control.
And this gets back to this
other topic we talked about,
such as the liver's job being
to maintain a constant level
of blood sugars.
Most of you are very familiar
with blood sugar control
through diabetes.
You've probably heard that
this is under hormonal control,
that the job of insulin
is to lower blood glucose.
And you also have hormones
like epinephrine or glucagon
whose job is to
raise blood glucose.
Why do you want to
raise blood glucose?
Well, if you have some kind
of fight-or-flight response--
you see that lion, and
you need to run away,
your body has this
adrenaline rush.
That's what epinephrine is.
That basically wants to supply
more energy to your muscles,
so that you can run
away effectively.
So it turns out, both
insulin and glucose act
on lots of tissues in the body.
I'm going to focus on
what they do in the liver.
And that's because
in the liver, this
is a major organ that
regulates blood glucose levels.
So if you have excess glucose
around, what do you want to do?
You want to stimulate
glucose uptake
into cells, its metabolism,
and its storage.
And so insulin with
high blood sugar
basically wants to stimulate,
taking glucose into the liver
and storing it as glycogen.
If you want to run
away from the lion,
well, now you have
epinephrine around.
You want to make
sure that as you're
consuming that
glucose in your blood
that you're continually
making more.
And so you want the epinephrine
to stimulate release of glucose
either from gluconeogenesis
or from the breakdown
of glycogen. And both
of these hormones act--
insulin and epinephrine--
act at a level
where they can regulate
enzymes of glycolysis
and gluconeogenesis as well
as entry and exit of glucose
monomers in and out of glycogen.
And so this is an example of
how fructose 2,6-bisphosphate
works.
And so remember you learned
from Professor Yaffe
that epinephrine acts via
cyclic AMP signaling, which
turns on a kinase--
protein kinase A. And that
protein kinase A can regulate
enzymes that produce or
break down, basically,
these enzymes that produce
or break down fructose
2,6-bisphosphatase
which, in turn,
regulates PFK activities such
that you can match your need
to burn that glucose versus
doing gluconeogenesis
in the case of the liver, so you
can do enough gluconeogenesis
in order to have glucose around
for the body to use in that
fight-or-flight response
being driven by epinephrine.
Now a major effective insulin
and epinephrine signaling,
though, is actually on release
or storage of glucose molecules
in glycogen. And I alluded
last time in talking
about the regulation hexokinase
that glucose 6-phosphate is
basically the entry point
to get glucose units in
and out of glycogen.
And I want to discuss
how you add and
subtract those glucose
units into storage polymers.
Now I'm going to discuss it
in the context of glycogen
storage in humans.
But remember, plants
actually store things also
as glucose polymers.
The chemistry is very similar.
But, obviously, the
regulation is very different.
Now you'll hopefully
recall from past
lectures that these storage
polymers of glucose--
glycogen in humans,
starch in plants--
are basically these alpha 1,4
linkages of glucose molecules.
Remember, there was
a non-reducing end
and a reducing end
of the molecule.
So starch was a
straight-chain polymer.
Glycogen had these
alpha 1,6 branch points
that made this
branch polymer, where
there's lots of non-reducing
ends and a single reducing end.
And each of these
non-reducing ends
is a polymer of glucose
molecules with this alpha 1,4
linkage that, at the branch
point, has this alpha 1,6
linkage to make this
long-chain branched polymer.
Now when we discussed
this at the time,
I mentioned that this
is useful because you
have all these
non-reducing ends that
can be used to add or
subtract glucose monomers.
And that's great.
This is a nice compact form
of storage with lots of places
to put or remove glucose from.
You either store
it quickly, insulin
driving glucose storage--
or remove it quickly,
epinephrine driving release
of glucose from the glycogen.
And so if we're going to have
a way to add glucose polymers
or break them down, those are
two separate pathways, just
like glycolysis and
gluconeogenesis--
reciprocal activities,
but we need two pathways
to do it because delta G has to
be less than 0 for each pathway
to work.
Also, we have to be able to
regulate these separately
because we don't want
to have a futile cycle.
Now the way you add and subtract
glucose polymers to glycogen
acts through glucose 6-phosphate
being first converted
to glucose 1-phosphate.
So this, here, is alpha
glucose 6-phosphate.
Remember, it's alpha because I
drew that hydroxyl at the one
position pointing down.
This, obviously, can
enter glycolysis and come
in from glucose via hexokinase.
All right.
This is first converted
via a mutase reaction
to move the phosphate from the
6 to the 1 position of glucose.
So this, here, is
glucose 1-phosphate.
The way the mutase
reaction works
is exactly the same
analogous mechanism
that I explained for
phosphoglycerate mutase
in glycolysis--
moves the phosphate in this case
from the 6 to the 1 position
of glucose.
And then once you have that
glucose 1-phosphate, that
can be added to a non-reducing
end of a glycogen polymer
using an enzyme called
Glycogen Synthase, GS.
So that'll give me
a glycogen molecule
with one additional monomer
added to the non-reducing end
of the polymer.
And you release that
glucose back off
via a different pathway,
a different enzyme
called phosphorylase.
All right.
Now the activity
of these enzymes--
glycogen synthase
and phosphorylase--
that is, the pathway to add
glucose 1-phosphate glucose
monomer to the polymer versus
remove it from the polymer
is under hormonal signaling
control in animals.
And basically, that hormonal
signaling works as follows.
So phosphorylase can
be phosphorylated
or dephosphorylated via a
signaling enzyme, an enzyme
like phosphorylase
kinase, which is
downstream of PKA, which is
downstream of epinephrine
signaling.
OK.
And so when phosphorylase is
phosphorylated by phosphorylase
kinase-- that has, has a
phosphate group added is
a signaling cascade--
it is in the active state.
And when it's dephosphorylated,
it's in the inactive state.
Well, glycogen synthase also
is subject to regulation
by protein phosphorylation
on the enzyme by a kinase.
Except this has the
opposite relationship.
So when it is in the
phosphorylated state,
it is inactive.
But it is in the
non-phosphorylated state,
it is active.
And so protein kinase A, which
is downstream of epinephrine,
can both activate
phosphorylation
of phosphorylase and
glycogen synthase.
And that makes sense.
You want to release
glycogen glucose monomers
from glycogen. You turn on, by
phosphorylation, the pathway
to release them.
And you turn off the
pathway to store them.
Another kinase
that phosphorylates
to glycogen synthase is a kinase
called GSK or Glycogen Synthase
Kinase.
This kinase is inhibited
by insulin signaling.
And so this is a
negative of a negative.
So effectively, a
negative of a negative
will keep it in
the inactive state.
And so insulin, by
inhibiting the ability of GSK
to put glycogen synthase
in the inactive state,
will make glycogen
synthase active.
And when you have
high insulin around,
that actives glycogen
synthesis, and you
store glucose
monomers as glycogen.
Get them out of the blood.
OK.
Now let's discuss
the chemistry that
allows us to do this glycogen
synthase and phosphorylates
reactions.
Now as we go through
this, what you will see
is that when we break down the
polymer, energy is released.
So that's going to be
breaking down a polymer.
That's the right
direction of entropy.
And so that's going
to be released.
And storing it is going
to require energy.
That is, you're going to
have to have some energy
input to build a polymer.
But nature actually
does this in a way that
is actually quite efficient.
First, let's talk about how you
store glucose 1-phosphate units
by adding them to glycogen.
So this uses energy input
from UTP, which is an ATP
equivalent for exactly
the reason I described earlier.
That is, because ATP plus UDP,
like any other interconversion
of nucleoside triphosphates
and diphosphates
is very close to equilibrium.
So the UTP to UDP ratio should
be similar to the ATP the ADP
ratio.
And so UTP is really
an ATP equivalent.
But nature, for whatever
reason, decided to use UTP here.
And it generates a nucleoside
sugar called UDP glucose.
And so let me show
you what that is.
So here is glucose 1-phosphate.
I will draw a stylized
version of UTP here.
And so this molecule with
the UDP added to the glucose
is UDP glucose.
This will also generate
a pyrophosphate.
And that pyrophosphate
can be hydrolyzed
to generate two inorganic
phosphates, effectively,
like building any other polymer,
by doing this downstream--
keeping that product of
the first reaction low
helps pull that reaction
forward for polymer synthesis.
This UDP glucose can now react
with the non-reducing end.
So this, here, will be
the non-reducing end
of the polymer.
That's the OH group
at the 4 position,
at the non-producing end.
And so that then
generates that alpha 1,4
bond to add to the polymer.
So here, we have glycogen
n plus 1 plus releases UDP.
And so the net to add
a glucose 1-phosphate
to the non-reducing end of
the growing glycogen polymer
is net conversion
of a UTP to a UDP.
So that is one ATP equivalent
to add glucose 1-phosphate
to the end of the polymer.
Now, of course,
you had it to also
have an ATP from hexokinase
to capture that glucose
6-phosphate to begin with.
But effectively, this
is two ADP molecules
to add a glucose to
glycogen. All right.
Now if we're generating starch,
that's all we have to do,
just build a long polymer.
But if we're making
glycogen, remember,
glycogen has all of these
branch points on them as well.
And to do the branch
points, you basically
have to make this alpha 1,6
bond, which then gives you
two new non-reducing ends that
you can add more subunits to.
The way nature does
this is as follows.
And so if I just draw this
here in a stylized way,
it turns out, once you
get to about seven units
here in the growing polymer--
so this is the reducing end,
and this is the non-reducing end
of the polymer.
And so the polymer is growing
by adding things to that end.
Once you get about
seven, there's
an enzyme that will basically
cleave this, and move it
and make a new alpha 1,6 bond.
OK.
Here we go.
We have our reducing
and our non-reducing end
and basically transfers
these 7 units over.
And now, we have two
non-reducing ends
that we can continue to
grow the polymer from.
You can think of this
like the airplane analogy.
When you load an airplane,
at least the way that's
most efficient,
the people who are
sitting in the back of the
plane, they get on first.
But then, they're
the last people off
the plane because
you add basically
to these non-reducing
ends, and then
you subtract from those
non-reducing ends.
And so the first glucose added,
the one at the reducing end,
is the last one that
is going to be removed.
All right.
Now phosphorylase
is the enzyme that
allows you to do the
opposite-- that is,
to break that alpha 1,4
bond and release monomers.
And it's called
phosphorylase because it
uses phosphate to break
that alpha 1,4 bond,
taking advantage of the fact
that breaking down the polymer
is favorable and actually
releasing the glucose from it
again is a glucose 1-phosphate.
And so at the non-reducing
end of the molecule--
so this, here, would
be the non-reducing end
of the glycogen polymer.
You basically have a phosphate
molecule that takes that off,
so you have a glycogen n minus
1 plus a glucose 1 phosphate,
which can now undergo
a mutase reaction back
to glucose 6-phosphate
that could then be released
from the cell if
it's a liver, or it
could be burned in glycolysis.
Now, obviously, if you're
doing breakdown, that is,
your chewing back from
non-reducing ends,
eventually, you're going
to hit a situation where
you come to where there's just a
nub here with an alpha 1,6 bond
there.
That is, chew it back till
you hit this single monomer
with a non-reducing end here
to this alpha 1,6 break point.
Turns out, you just cleave
off that nub, if you will.
And so that nub is then just
released as free glucose.
So other than release of
that nub, what it means
is that you actually
basically get
no ATP to actually break down
in the phosphorylase reaction.
So the net cost to store a
glucose 1-phosphate molecule
is one ATP via the UTP to UDP
conversion in the glycogen
synthase reaction.
And you get that one
glucose 1-phosphate back.
And so two ATPs to put
a glucose tin glycogen.
And then you get
it directly back
out as a glucose 1-phosphate.
That's a phosphorylated glucose
that can then enter glycolysis.
So that's one less phosphate
you need to spend on glycolysis.
And so it's incredibly efficient
to store glucose in that way.
And so it's actually
slightly greater than one ATP
to store it as glycogen because
you lose in ATP with that nub
removal at the branch polymer.
But for all intents
and purposes,
it costs one ATP to store
your glucose as glycogen,
which is pretty amazing.
All right.
Now before I leave the
topic of sugar storage,
I want to make some comments
on some sugars that are stored
in forms other than glucose.
And want to talk about
these because these sugars
are, of course, important
parts of our diet.
And so as we've mentioned
in prior lectures,
two of these sugars are
sucrose and lactose.
So remember, sucrose
is a disaccharide
of glucose plus fructose.
And lactose is a disaccharide
of glucose plus galactose.
So those are storage
forms of sugar-- sucrose
in the case of plants,
lactose in the case
of milk made by mammals.
And so to break
those sugars down,
basically, you break
the disaccharide.
Now, you have the
glucose molecules
you know how to handle.
That's glycolysis.
But I want to spend
a little bit of time
how you deal with the
fructose and the galactose
that you get out
from these sugars
because this actually
relates to some things
that I'm sure you've all
read about in the news.
For instance, fructose
as a sugar in our diet
is actually quite controversial.
Lots of stuff out there
that says fructose
was cooked up in the devil's
kitchen and is this evil thing.
There's actually
others who argue
that, oh, fructose is
the same as glucose,
the same number of calories.
There's both sides
of the debate.
Both sides are actually
making factual claims.
And I want you to
understand the biochemistry,
so you can actually
judge for yourself
who's right in those claims.
All right.
So let's start with
talking about how
you metabolize fructose.
And so fructose is first
captured by phosphorylation
to generate fructose
1-phosphate.
This is carried out by an
enzyme called ketohexokinase.
Ketohexokinase is an
enzyme this present
in your gut and your liver.
And so fructose in the diet,
from breaking down sucrose
or from high-fructose
corn syrup, whatever,
is captured with ketohexokinase
to make fructose 1-phosphate.
Turns out that
phosphofructokinase,
our old friend from
glycolysis, is less efficient
than ketohexokinase but can
also carry out this reaction.
And remember, what is
it do in glycolysis?
It adds a phosphate
to the 1 position
of fructose 6-phosphate.
Well, it can also
add a phosphate
to the 1 position of fructose
give you fructose 1-phosphate.
OK.
Once you have this fructose
1-phosphate, which, remember,
is not in glycolysis,
it can be a substrate
for the glycolytic
enzyme aldolase.
What does aldolase
do in glycolysis?
It splits FBP into
dihydroxyacetone phosphate
and glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate.
Well, here, you only have a
phosphate on the 1 position.
And so if you look back at how
aldolase works, what you'll see
is that if aldolase acts
on fructose 1-phosphate,
you'll generate a
dihydroxyacetone phosphate.
That phosphate will go to the
dihydroxyacetone half, which,
of course, is perfectly good
substrate for glycolysis.
The other product of aldolase
acting on fructose 1-phosphate
is just glyceraldehyde
without the phosphate on it.
And then there's
another enzyme that
will phosphorylate
glyceraldehyde to generate
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate,
which can then also, of course,
enter glycolysis.
And so fructose is a
hexose just like glucose.
You generate two trioses--
DHAP and glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
That costs you two ATP to
do it, exactly the same cost
is what you spent to get glucose
to make DHAP and glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate.
And so people are
absolutely right when
they say metabolizing
fructose has
exactly the same caloric cost
as metabolizing glucose--
two ATPs to get it
into the trioses.
And then whatever
you get out of it,
you get out of it
two ATPs, four ATPs--
so net two ATPs if you
just do fermentation, more
if you do complete oxidation.
But the bottom line is
that from that standpoint,
you get exactly the
same number of calories
from burning glucose
versus fructose.
However, I want to point out
that the regulation will not
be the same.
And that's because in
this fructose metabolism,
you will notice that there
was no glucose 6-phosphate
and no FBP generated.
That means you are avoiding
all of the feedbacks
that control how much glucose
you send to glycolysis--
first to glycogen.
Remember, that's
what glucose 6-phosphate does,
acting on trapping sugar.
And more importantly,
you're actually
not using
phosphofructokinase in a way
to fit with the rest of
the feedback regulation.
I also show that
here on this slide.
It's basically a better
version of what I drew up here.
And I now want to point
out this storage of citrate
and this feedback
regulation of citrate.
So we'll talk
about the specifics
of this more in other lectures.
But it turns out,
citrate is the precursor
for how one stores
carbon as fat.
And so if you're
putting fructose glucose
into the system and
citrate is too high,
it'll shut off
phosphofructokinase
and stop carbon coming
down the system,
shunting it instead to glycogen
or just saying don't give me
any more glucose at all.
If I'm doing the same
thing with fructose,
those feedbacks don't exist.
Citrate doesn't feed back
on any of the enzymes that
are regulated for
fructose metabolism.
And so the idea is
carbon keeps getting
dumped into citrate, which
ultimately ends up as fat.
And this really underlies, at
least on a theoretical basis,
why there may be a connection
between fructose and obesity or
metabolic syndrome.
I've posted articles on Stellar,
one from The Popular Press,
one from a scientific journal
that discusses the controversy,
discusses this.
But now, at least, you
have the background
to draw some of your
own conclusions.
OK.
That's fructose metabolism.
What about galactose metabolism?
Well, galactose metabolism
interfaces with, effectively,
glycogen metabolism or, at
least, glucose 1-phosphate--
or sorry, UDP glucose
and does so in a way that
is a little bit non-intuitive.
But it's actually very
important to understand
galactose metabolism, at
least for those of you
who are looking to
go to medical school.
It turns out that galactose
metabolism and issues
with metabolizing
galactose are what
underlie a set of rare
genetic diseases leading
to a set of conditions
called galactosemias.
I guess, if you're
a pediatrician,
you may encounter these.
If you're not, these
are quite rare.
Although med schools
love to ask about these,
and certainly, they're
very popular on things
like board exams.
So it's something you
should know about.
And so I just want to briefly
introduce galactose metabolism
to you.
So this is galactose.
Like all sugars,
galactose is initially
trapped by phosphorylation.
It's phosphorylated on
the 1 position to trap it,
just like fructose.
And so this is
galactose 1-phosphate.
Remember, galactose is
an epimer of glucose.
So it differs from glucose
here by the stereochemistry
of the hydroxyl group
at this 4 carbon.
And so the way
galactose, once it's
trapped as galactose
1-phosphate is metabolized
is it will react
with UDP glucose.
So here is UDP glucose
from glycogen metabolism
drawn in a very stylized way.
That will generate
a UDP galactose
and a glucose
1-phosphate, which,
of course, can enter
glycolysis, can be
stored as glycogen, et cetera.
This UDP galactose can then
be turned into UDP glucose
via an epimerase reaction.
And so remember, the
epimerase reaction
needs to change
the stereochemistry
of the hydroxyl group
at this 4 position,
such that it's pointing
up in galactose
or pointing down in glucose.
The way epimerases work is
that they require a cofactor.
That cofactor is NAD.
and they work in
the following way.
And so if I just draw, here's
the 4 position of galactose,
the 4 carbon of galactose, with
the hydroxyl group pointing up,
an epimerase can
basically remove
a hydride from the bottom
face of the molecule,
transfer those two electrons
to NAD to generate NADH.
Now, you get this lactone
intermediate at the 4 carbon.
And then you can have two
electrons from an NADH can be
added to the opposite face of
the molecule that regenerates
an NAD+.
And now, we've effectively
changed the stereochemistry
at the 4 carbon
to now be pointing
such the hydroxyl points
down, and that's glucose.
And so the way epimerases
work is they basically
remove and add electrons
from different faces
of the pyranose ring.
And that changes
the stereochemistry
of which direction the
hydroxyl group is pointing.
And so effectively, this
is how we metabolize
all kinds of different
sugars, either
putting them in glycogen
or other starch,
some other storage
carbohydrate that we
can get them later,
and then use them
in glycolysis as a way to drive
glucose oxidation as a way
to release energy and
keep ATP high in the cell.
All right.
Now I want to shift
topics and begin
to discuss how we
can oxidize pyruvate
from glycolysis to make
CO2 as an alternative
to how we can release energy
from carbohydrate oxidation
rather than just
use fermentation.
Now you'll see that the enzymes
and ways that we do this
is going to also be
how we make citrate.
And so this isn't just
about releasing energy.
It's also about storing
energy because you'll see,
citrate is a precursor
for storage as fat.
The reactions downstream
of pyruvate oxidation
also make lots of other
useful intermediates
that can be used to synthesize
other things cells need--
amino acids, nucleic acids.
And so this pathways
we're going to discuss
are going to come up
over and over again
throughout the course.
Now to facilitate
this discussion,
I'm really going to at least
initially focus on catabolism.
And so just to remind
you, if we do glycolysis
by turning glucose pyruvate,
this involves oxidation.
So we need to dispose of
those electrons somewhere.
In other words, that NADH
has to be regenerated NAD.
Fermentation of pyruvate
into something like lactate
is a way to do that and
allows net ATP production
from glycolysis without
the need for any oxygen.
However, if we're going
to completely oxidize
that pyruvate CO2 we're going
to generate many more electrons
as waste that we have
to put somewhere.
Oxygen is a particularly
good electron acceptor.
And so we can reduce
oxygen to water
as a way to deal with
that electron waste,
and that allows us
to, just burning wood,
release lots of
energy from glucose
by transferring those
electrons ultimately to oxygen.
And of course,
that same process--
oxygen to water-- if we're using
the pyruvate to fully oxidize
it, also is necessary
to regenerate
the NAD to run glycolysis.
Now ultimately, the
series of reactions
that allow chemically
conversion of pyruvate to CO2
is called the TCA cycle for
try Tricarboxylic Acid Cycle
or sometimes referred
to as the Krebs cycle
and also is referred to
as the citric acid cycle--
so TCA, Tricarboxylic
Acid Cycle, Krebs cycle,
citric acid cycle--
all synonyms for the same thing.
What these cycles
are is basically
a way to take two carbon units.
And those two carbon
units can come
from the oxidation of
pyruvate or from the oxidation
of lots of other fuels.
And those two carbon
units are combined
with four carbon units.
You'll see oxaloacetate
is the four-carbon unit--
oxaloacetate gluconeogenesis.
That oxaloacetate could come
from the pyruvate-carboxylase
reaction.
Or it could come, as you'll
see, from the TCA cycle itself.
This generates a six-carbon
molecule, which is citrate.
Citrate is a tricarboxylic acid,
hence the citric acid cycle
or the tricarboxylic acid cycle.
And then those six
carbon units are
reoxidized, releasing
two CO2 molecules,
back to four-carbon
oxaloacetate.
And hence, this is a cycle.
Now this cycle was
initially described
by Hans Krebs, who
predicted the cycle largely
based on chemistry-- one
of the most amazing feats
in the discovery of metabolism.
Turned out, he was right.
And thus, it's also referred to
as his name, the Krebs cycle.
Now lots of oxidation is
happening in this cycle.
You're oxidizing the
molecule, releasing CO2.
That means lots of
energy is released.
Those electrons ultimately will
be transferred oxygen. And so
we can use this to make lots of
ATP and do lots of other work.
Where are these reactions all
occur is in the mitochondria,
specifically in the matrix
of the mitochondria.
Remember, the mitochondria,
from cell biology,
is a double-membrane organelle.
The innermost part
of the mitochondria
is referred to as the matrix.
And these have conditions that
favor pyruvate carboxylase
reaction, as I talked
about, but also favor
other oxidation
reactions, such as those
that occur in the TCA cycle.
And so next time,
what I will start with
is by being more explicit about
what chemistry is happening
to allow these two
carbon units to combine
with oxaloacetate 4-carbon to
generate citrate and go over
the reactions that then
allow you to run a cycle
to regenerate oxaloacetate, that
is, run the TCA cycle as a way
to oxidize carbon.
Thanks.